comment elle s'appelait Anne Sinclair
j'aimerais vraiment avoir un interview
avec ce genre de calibre mental
c'est OK volontiers
je vais vous montrer tout de suite
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et comme faire payer 8 dollars par mois
pour une virgule qui ressemble à une
médaille de poney ne suffira pas musk a
annoncer qu'il allait licencier 3750
employés soit la moitié de la boîte ce
qui reste eux ont interdiction de faire
du télétravail
chef
deadlines
vous avez vu ce jeune de quartier tout à
l'heure qui disait d'ailleurs dans la
présentation il fait pas grand chose
Gérald Darma
manifestement les comment dire
de quartier n'essayez pas de me piéger
ça c'est pas gentil tu es sympa si je
vous le dis c'est parce que lui-même en
parle et qui va poser la question donc
là je vois que vous voulez jouer à Yann
Barthès avec moi mais ça c'est pas bien
du tout ça c'est pas bien du tout
monsieur le ministre
absolu les différents programmes que
j'ai cités y contribue seulement soit
j'aurais pas dû boire autant de passoire
hier soir bordel
je vous remercie alors que le député
elle est fi Carlos Martin bilongo tente
d'alerter sur le drame de l'immigration
clandestine il est interrompu par un
député du rassemblement national les
personnes secourues se trouvent dans une
situation d'urgence absolue les
prévisions météo indiquent une
détonation significative du climat
pas du tout
c'est
immédiatement l'assemblée
qui ont été commis la présidente suspend
la séance et la polémique enfle
aujourd'hui on m'a renvoyé à ma couleur
de peau je suis né en France je suis
député français et je pensais pas
aujourd'hui qu'à la semaine nationale
vous allez me faire insulter moi je les
vois absolument pas stressée
j'ai la limite aux échiquiers quoi au
bout d'un moment pour eux ils ont
tellement de joker
du coup ils font ce qu'il y a ils ont
que des pions donc pour eux ça leur fait
ni chenille froid de faire partir
quelqu'un et cette insulte raciste d'un
député RN à l'Assemblée tombe au plus
mal pour le rassemblement national qui
organise cette semaine l'élection de son
nouveau président et justement écoutez
comment Louis a lieu justifié sa
candidature ce matin sur France Inter
que vous portez lui à Lyon vous pensez
vraiment gagner ça fait 20 ans que je
combat avec Marie sur cette ligne de
dédiabolisation au sein du rassemblement
national et il y a aucune raison que je
ne me présente pas à cette élection ok
bon là regarde là franchement on y est
sur un gros Lego ça aurait fait encore
plus mal
non je crois pas je crois que
tu ne l'as jamais fait ça plus les
petits plus ça fait mal parce que le
gros tu marches dessus
[Rires]
OK
[Applaudissements]
quand j'ai dit qu'il retourne en Afrique
je ne parlais pas de du député qui est
en train de poser la question je parlais
du bateau pasteur de migrants nous
sommes en face d'une manipulation de la
France insoumise qui cherche à dénaturer
mes propos pour me faire tenir des
propos dégueulasses
[Musique]
laissez-le répondre
parce que tu sais très bien que si
j'avais envie de rentrer là-dedans tu es
moche je te les rentrerai un an dans ton
en regardant droit dans les yeux
[Musique]
comment peut-il et c'est la question que
je me suis posée toute la nuit en
préparant comment peut-il faire rentrer
les places par cet endroit là tout en
regardant par les yeux
chacun son style en force pour Monique
tout en souplesse pour Marcel quand leur
résidence Seigneur propose un atelier
jeu vidéo ils sont emballés
Mariana Varella Miss Argentine 2020 et
Fabiola Valentine Miss Porto Rico de la
même année ont annoncé leur union sur
Instagram elle s'était rencontrée il y a
deux ans lors de Miss grand
international concours crée par un homme
d'affaires thaïlandais depuis les deux
femmes qui avaient terminé dans le top
10 c'était inséparable mais leur
relation n'avait jamais été officialisée
la grande finale les opposés à François
et Roger champion d'Aquitaine en pleine
forme un strike et François un j'espère
pour Roger simonik commence un peu à
perdre confiance Marcel déroule double
strike 5 sphères et une victoire haut la
main 278 à 233
[Applaudissements]
j'ai réussi à me maintenir dans la forme
pour pouvoir jouer le mieux possible
d'abord je reçois tout le monde ici
comme vous le savez je reçois tout le
monde ici parfois les gens qui veulent
pas venir mais vraiment si Sandrine ou
soit venir s'il y a des scope à venir si
Monsieur Dupont-Moretti veut venir tout
le monde peut venir sur ce plateau tout
le monde moi je suis ouvert mais
attention
les médias dominants on invite pas
n'importe qui
on ouvre la bouche
à taper sur le Syndicat de la
magistrature c'est pas dans la bonne
idéologie du moment pour le service
public donc on écoute pas monsieur
Lehmann parce qu'il n'a pas le droit de
parler bien sûr une exception évidemment
il y a une exception c'est France
Culture